hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the
witch's house okay we died a horrible
death the last time we came in here and
you guys mention to me that I needed to
go I forgot about that and I needed to
go back to some room because I missed a
big scare apparently that for some
reason I want to find so that you guys
can see me scream like a little girl
maybe I don't know if that's necessarily
gonna happen but let's see what zoton it
was back here in this room in this
really quiet room with the dripping
blood that I love so much so what did I
miss in here besides the dripping blood
and the giant fissure what did I miss
there's nothing here okay there was
nothing there that I saw and there's no
door to go back there so maybe I own a
it was over there
oh yeah that's wait a minute hang on
wait a minute hang on maybe I could have
fed that stuffed frog to the the snake
instead of feeding my pet frog to it
that that probably was the best thing
okay so I missed out on something that
you guys were mentioning what oh well I
guess I'll just go die a natural death
somewhere else unnatural death or
whatever you would call dying in this
horrible place okay into the giant mouth
down the throat out the back here we go
I need to make some noise in these rooms
so that this toy soldier does not
destroy me fake gun my ass okay so
there's a piano in here you need not
play well if you say so a book entitled
I studies
all right I'll read people have
different eye colors who knew Church we
know the following about women in this
region in particular ones eye color
depends on her hair for hair colors are
silver black golden red for our colors
are brown green blue and red red silver
haired women have red eyes brown-eyed
women can either have blonder oh my god
blonde or red do I need to remember any
of that I'm blonde and I have blue eyes
what does that mean okay whatever
it's locked there's some small text on
the door makes sound in four rooms yes I
understood that a gorgeous
don't kill me bro son of a [ __ ] I swear
I'll stab you with your own gun up your
butt okay anyway
we got blue eyes see the score I've got
blue eyes do I see the score there's a
pumpkin with a face hit the pumpkin
doesn't make much of a sound okay well
that's probably just enough sound to get
the toy soldier to kill me some playing
cards nothing to do with them okay
there's pictures of ladies oh I get it
oh I gotta go back to the book don't
kill me bro okay he didn't kill me I got
to go back to the book because there was
pictures of Mona Lisa's with four
different hair colors which totally make
sense
okay I studies read people gentlemen
we're gonna go magoo okay
so for our colors brown green okay
brown-eyed women can either a blonde or
red hair silver haired women have red
eyes that means black that means black
or gold haired women have blue eyes I
would imagine that it would be the
blonde lady but it could be the black
haired lady I have no idea anyway I
don't think it matters at this point
because I don't even think I'm close to
solving this puzzle in any way did I
read that yeah blue eyes see the score
and that means that's either the black
haired lady blond-haired lady your gaze
goes into the far distance her gaze go
into the forest distance gaze goes into
the far distance you see a white sheet
in the crack on the wall yes
Sookie laughing cuz I'm saying gays that
cyndago everybody
Cindy ha ha ha ha ha ha ha gay ok screw
you whatever it's so [ __ ] you were all
right so I'm gonna pick the blonde
haired woman whose gaze goes into the
far distance see white sheet stuck in
the crack okay great getting the sheet
music Oh
I died that's that not good okay that
was not good either but what the hell do
I need to do because I'm red-haired Leo
maybe was the red-haired lady because
that means okay guineas you know why
cheating the crack for the wall reach
for it allow and I got pulled in and
died wait a minute no I was right with
the black haired lady because I died
differently with the black haired lady
oh I just need to not go near her I need
I just need to not come towards wall
cake get the shape music yay
got it ha ha she turned me into a
painting I'll freakin how did I get out
of there I couldn't get out let's try
this one more time to cvz okay pull out
the sheet music got it
ah no out won't open and I'm dead page
maybe I got like go back to her painting
and seal her in or something I have no
idea this game so freaky sometimes just
with the noises it makes I've always
said that sound makes a good horror game
it's that right Daniel sound always
makes a good horror game because that's
what puts you know get the painting tear
down yes what what what what
well you're the musica Ryan does sound
make no sound make a good horror game
Ryan ah okay okay stupid little girls
trying to nibble on my giblets no no
they're not that sounded weird that
sounded really rude okay I need to don't
play I need to put sheet music on the
grand piano no don't play Alice see out
no don't play cuz I didn't save gotta go
down and save with the kitty cat kitty
cat save you thank you thank you very
much
and now we gonna play it so that we can
see how we die play it and it sucked me
in and slam me down yeah didn't you know
all right go back to the sing put the
sheet music on the thing then go my
merry way no don't play it there we go
item G music place done play it fine it
sucked me and then slam me down a few
times what the hell it's not fair of
this bull okay maybe if I put sheet
music down it will automatically play
because it's one of those ghost pianos
place you'd music cool do nothing though
yeah alright it's a ghost piano the
piano begins playing itself
what is that entail for me oh hello the
vase shook and spat out a turn key got a
kinky array I guess that mean I can get
out there's some small text on the door
makes sounded forums okay I made sound
in one room successfully don't kill me
bro oh yeah that's right you're not
gonna kill me this time all right cool
so I now have a key which means that I
could prob no uh I saw that lady you go
to hell and you die
okay so with a king graved and it's
obviously not for man I won't open can't
unlock that one mean
let me Mick hit it yeah okay not that
one
hit it thump yeah keep hitting it haha I
opened it yeah somehow magically
I knew something would happen okay so
now we're in a room with a statue am i
woman did you look like woman baby uh
yes
oh oh oh no wrong oh no I would it
didn't kill me for once it just sent me
out of the room that's so weird
okay and the room it's we're not rum rum
it's rum I played it for you in the
dictionary
I played the dictionary it says room and
my man I'm gonna say yeah you look like
a man what the hell that's not right
isn't it right is wrong big pumpkin foot
I'm gonna a my o'clock yep thank you I'm
right what Oh a turnkey fella
I got a queen key okay
sundial sand hourglass bird cuckoo clock
cue clock okay what does that mean I
have no idea but oh well whatever cool
beans
got it nailing it oh we win I got
another room somehow magically yay for
me okay so now okay
thank you goodbye forever okay so I need
to make music here but I'm not gonna
play the music box with 12 with one two
maybe one one and two
I don't know what that means do you guys
know what that means play the music box
with 12 was that funny it's not funny
tell me what to do if I don't know what
that means I don't have a 12 button
no I do not her in it is not you liars
whatever okay so there was something
about the thing oh it's a
jack-in-the-box cool cool alright then
what about that was that noise enough
followed me did you see that well okay
alright so there's this room here glass
cupboard shadow cross I saw that the
other day okay that fell was that enough
noise a coat rack the hand has fallen
off Fantasma coal was that mean don't
you me okay what does that mean what
does it mean I don't know plays a music
box with I'm gonna stink it's like one
two it's missing its key don't play hang
on me Queen key insert cwienke play them
okay okay it's that dragon the lock is
not missing its face or its face is all
red what does that mean I think this is
the last room and let me try the no
can't do that okay what do I do
this is the only other room that there
is isn't there and this guy's gonna
shoot me as soon as I come out of this
room right right right right right oh he
didn't oh yeah I'm the Griggs hang on I
have an idea maybe maybe like the
cupboard is like the closet to Narnia
and I need to put the King key in it
no no is that not it my rosette hey I
saw something here hey hey now don't be
weird
okay teacup music box what's that even
mean maybe I got to put the kinky in
this No okay so I am at a loss 12 is the
Queen card okay oh that's what it Oh put
cream
the 12th cart okay shut up
swearing ah my why would you give me
that clue afterwards I should have
realized that and that's when I was
right with a queen key but whatever
can't go in this room oh yeah wait hang
on pinky no all right I need oh wait no
I know I need to make the grandpa hoodie
that's me that's me
really I'm a strong black guy that's who
I am okay here we go yeah something's
chained in here it's not ticking well
let's stick the King key in it good
going why was that me are you just
giggling to yourselves now who it's
still not ticking I stuck the King key
in it can't reach all okay I ah piss
crap I just I screwed myself hang on we
scooped there we go okay do not push the
chair to the left or push it to the
right push it to the left and then go up
on it okay here we go boo boo boo boo
boo doo doo Bing bong Bing bong yay Oh
sound was made in all the rooms yay
hurtin unlocking sound somewhere hooray
we're gonna make it it was with that
beautiful collection of lilies yes all
right
kittycat we're going oh you toy soldier
[ __ ] you son of a [ __ ] your legs are
bent good bent forever
the door opened oh oh don't like this
sobbing statue of a woman hi my ring
it's not here okay good for you
I just broke into a hole in the wall I
am strong pry the door that was probably
a bad idea
hang on no Pete Oh
I died died it just chop my head off
like instantly do you like my panic fly
really yeah
when you two were like together in pink
no whoa hey whoa whoa sorry sorry sir
so tired so many all right hang tear
this hole in the wall crawl in that's
smart
which is diary I don't like illness but
it kept me from going outside because it
made no one love me oh because it kept
me okay flower adorns a desk
land has not lit lamp lamp is not lit
well how am I supposed to get through
there without killing myself I don't
have a ring whatever what happened why
big noise go boom what just happened
what oh that's interesting
okay let's crawl into the room fireplace
fireplace look inside yes stick your
head in there's a hole in an iron ladder
going down yep let's go oh wait no wait
hang on I got a stop I've been recording
for too long so thank you all so much
for watching I know who's kind of an
abrupt ending so thank you guys again
for all the moral support when I'm going
through these games not you thank you
guys again everybody for watching click
the annotation for more things that I've
done and as always I will see you
war in the next video